[Música]
y siendo así es hora de ir en directo
hasta Argentina este jueves el actual
alcalde de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
Horacio Rodríguez larreta entró en la
carrera por la presidencia el
funcionario postuló su nombre para
competir por la candidatura de la
coalición opositora juntos que se
definirá en las primarias de agosto de
este año Rodríguez larreta se podría
establecer como uno de los principales
aspirantes opositores Debido al apoyo
del expresidente de Mauricio macri y su
más reciente disputa con el gobierno
nacional por el recorte de fondos
públicos para la ciudad para hablar de
esta noticia conectamos con nuestro
corresponsal en Buenos Aires en natalio
cosoy buenas noches natalio y cómo
cambia la postulación de Rodríguez
larreta La baraja por la candidatura de
la oposición se ha mostrado con un
perfil menos combativo que quienes hasta
ahora han postulado sus nombres como la
misma Patricia bullrich
si es interesante habíamos esperaba se
esperaba totalmente esta presentación de
candidatura o precandidatura el momento
lo único que no se sabía era cuándo
bueno fue fue ahora
esa apuesta al centro por ahí tiene que
ver con lo que ocurrió durante la
pandemia que él se acercó al gobierno
Nacional Contra la insistencia de otros
sectores dentro de su propia coalición
de romper con el gobierno nacional y tal
vez en ese en ese contexto sintió que
debería ir por ese lado como vos bien
decías Patricia bullrich se corre más
hacia un lugar de confrontación con el
por supuesto por la candidatura de su
espacio pero también con el gobierno
nacional y también se presentó una
precandidatura María Eugenia Vidal
exgobernadora de la provincia de Buenos
Aires también de este espacio y cuidado
Mauricio macri apareció con ella y no es
que le dio un respaldo total a Rodríguez
larreta sino dijo que le da la
bienvenida a su participación y a la
competencia dentro de su espacio y
todavía no podemos descartar al 100% que
él también intente una nueva postulación
a la presidencia
natalio del lado del oficialismo qué
nombres resuenan en las filas del
kirchnerismo en medio de la duda de si
Alberto Fernández apunta o no a la
reelección
hay menos Claridad y menos definiciones
Hace unos días en la semana pasada hubo
una reunión para justamente ir
definiendo Cómo van a presentarse en el
contexto de estas elecciones lo que es
el frente de todos que es sobre todo una
coalición peronista Alberto Fernández
está coqueteando con la idea de ir a un
intento de reelección con muchísima
dificultad seguramente aquellos que son
presidentes en América Latina han tenido
muchísimas dificultades para renovar
mandato en general les ha ido mal sobre
todo después de la pandemia resuena el
nombre de Cristina Fernández de kirchner
la vicepresidenta y expresidenta ya dijo
que no tenía planes de postularse pero
desde los sectores más afines a ellas
están pidiéndole que intente rever esa
decisión y ver si se puede presentar hay
otros nombres en danzas también por
ejemplo el ministro de economía Sergio
Maza que todavía no confirmó ni negó no
ha tenido una definición concreta pero
es un nombre posible también de
candidatura del oficialismo Pues natalio
seguimos de cerca la carrera
presidencial que además en su día
estaremos cu briendo de manera especial
en France 24 gracias